a little upsetting that we kept pain and
struggled and through everything and
then other people just gave up and quit
what'd you say to Brian and others who
say that this is really not fair that
the student loan is just one kind of
debt and there are other people who
don't have that but have other struggles
that the government isn't helping them
with you know I think a lot about
fairness and I think about how education
debt is different from other debt our
public education system is no longer
creating opportunities for kids like me
and other kids whose families can't
afford to write a check that's not the
America we want we want to be an America
of opportunity yeah but I'm not sure
that this relieving this amount of debt
changes the cost of college part of what
it does is it deals with the debt has
been built up because the cost of
college has gone up because taxpayers
have made fewer investments in our
public colleges and universities